[Music]
great job
his tweets angered the mob now he's out
of a job i speak of a 24 year old from
michigan aren't they all
named griffin green he recently moved to
the bronx for a job in nyc
so already we know he has bad judgment
but upon arrival he had a hard time
shopping at local bodegas which is what
people call all the small grocery stores
here in new york these are places where
you can buy over or you can overpay for
detergent beer and cold medicine while a
cat sleeps on a loaf of wonder bread
true take it away griffin
okay so just moved to new york and i'm
trying to go grocery shopping and so i
typed in like grocery stores and my
apple maps
and like every one i go to like i'm
walking too like they're like this
or like
like this like bro that's not a grocery
store like i'm trying to get like egg
yogurt like cheese like like that like
look at this place like i've literally
been to like five of those now and like
i don't know what they're about to do
for dinner like where are the krogers
and like the whole foods at like i'm
about to eat
like
like cereal and ramen for dinner like
what the
it's great
so that clip made the rounds on twitter
with people calling him a racist for
some reason then some busybody losers
tweeted his new place of work a software
company called outreach demanding that
he be fired
so they did
but now they say he was fired for
sharing a confidential employment letter
on social media but it's obvious that me
the mob did him in by scaring his
employer we reached out to griff that's
what i call him because we're tight
in griff
we bro down you just like saying griff
so bro down
and he never and he says he never meant
to trash the neighborhood adding quote
through this experience i've learned
that food deserts
are a huge issue
uh
in some urban areas across the country
new york specifically no idea i had no
idea this was what i was walking into i
was essentially a golden retriever that
stuck his nose in a bee's nest and got
stung
oh
it's a beautiful analogy
we'll be doing greeting cards he also
filmed himself buying food from bodegas
and then distributing it to the homeless
oh boy which is fine i guess but when i
do my charity work i never record it
that's just tacky also they won't let me
bring my camera into the chippendale's
dressing room
jeff hero or jerk
hmm i gotta pick one of the two yes
[Laughter]
oh you could come you can go you can say
well is this was he right to be fired uh
no i don't think it was his second day
on the job yeah i know and also i'm
shocked that he definitely works in tech
this guy's a tech guy yeah i know he
doesn't like it okay but also you know
i think we learned a lesson here you
know it's this is uh he's a bro that's
why people are mad you know you i live
in los angeles i'm a bro i'm a straight
white guy he's got to know you gotta lie
yeah
you gotta lie every day if you want to
keep working every day i have to say i'm
like oh nice to meet you the girl i
identify as a
wolf am my moon rising and i go yeah me
too
i say oh man can i have babies you're
like duh
duh you lie so you can work there you go
there you go he was naive he was a
victim of his own naivete tyrus did he
say any truth in there everything he
said was accurate uh
he just maybe films a little too close
to his face
[Laughter]
but i hope david
he's been and i just am shocked because
you can you know how you knew he was
from out of town he paid for everything
yeah
right that phone should have been
if he was
[Applause]
i'm saying if he would have robbed every
place he went out he'd have been a hero
yes that is so what he did was he made
some jokes
he didn't single anybody out and he gave
food to homeless yeah cancel this guy
yeah you know i hope this inspires him
because usually the stories like this
will turn into this guy starts opening
grocery stores all over the east coast
and he's going to look back on this day
and laugh yes you know i have a theory
that these bodegas are designed for
people like you cat
somebody at 2 30 in the morning weighs
80 pounds
like inside these like really narrow
things you buy like oh i think i'll buy
it i'll buy some hohos
i'll buy some jerky oh my god i'll buy
some
cat food
and then it's all and then you just
bring it all up there like this
at three it's like 2 30. you know me so
well
but it's
it's designed for people buying things
while they're slightly inebriated and
aren't looking at the prices right
maybe or noticing that maybe it's stale
you get home when you open it up it
usually is yes i don't know
i i feel like i do have to say this guys
he sucks really yeah not because like he
shouldn't have gotten fired but like
look at him you know like
there's there's so many like shirtless
gym mirror selfies of him that i that
are floating around
and he's just like the kind of guy that
would be like hitting on you on a at a
barn just never understanding no matter
how obvious that you were being about
not being into it and he gets all
excited when the chain smokers come on
like he's like
you are describing your husband yeah i
resemble these
isn't that your favorite no my husband
has i love him so much but he does have
the musical taste of a forever 21. yeah
which
does create issues sometimes but we can
talk about that later
[Laughter]
you know what emily i have to say that
if i i was probably closer to what he
was like back then i mean like i would
if i had social media at that age i
would have i never would have survived i
wouldn't have a job
but the point is we didn't thank god so
we don't have to talk about it
everything's cool actually we were
perfect yes exactly
exactly
i did nothing bad i feel like the
company
was breathed a sigh of relief when they
saw that he had posted that offer letter
they were like oh yes right because now
we actually do have this legal hook and
then they threw in though that comment
about how they're dedicated to inclusion
and diversity just in case
the mob comes after them too um you know
there was a gofundme account like set up
for him it's he's already raised over
four thousand dollars for himself and
the whole reason he got that's a lot of
axe body spray yeah
exactly
it's a lot of top ramen he's locked into
a year lease so he was saying he's like
screwed because now he doesn't have a
job and he is stuck here for 12 months
which is like a billion dollars but i
mean to your point earlier he can just
go to chippendales or we could hire him
to hire her what should he do no we
already have his twin who's that guy
andy
who's the guy in the back do you guys
use sometimes
to talk about
andre the guy
yeah he's always the guy who's asking
the monkey to have sex that's his one
rule
the
[Laughter]
yo this is the last bastion of
persecution are the bros can we admit
though that it's not racist at least
yeah yeah right yeah he might be a dummy
he might be young and stupid and on the
internet and definitely zoomed in i
agree with you yeah but uh but it's
definitely not it's we're all racing we
think bodegas aren't grocery stores
that's not a racist statement no it's no
he didn't say anything hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else